it's almost as if they get to run this
game every day with multiple companies
and all you're trying to do is raise
money and get back to work hey this is
michael seibel with dalton caldwell and
welcome to rookie mistakes
we've asked yc founders for their rookie
mistakes so we can share them with you
and help you avoid them here's the last
note written by a yc founder
you should care just as much about the
terms of your fundraise as you should
care about the economics the valuation
and the amount of
money you raise
there are lots of rights there are lots
of
terms inside of a funding deal that can
screw you no matter how high the
valuation is i think that investors are
aware that founders want high valuations
and they want the
press release
about
you know they raised a lot of dollars or
they raised at a high valuation or
whatever and so they're very aware of
this and so one of the ways that you
sometimes see investors take advantage
of this
need on the part of founders is to say
great we'll give you your ask around
valuation or amount but you need to give
us all this other stuff and often the
things they ask for are sort of jargon
filled inside baseball that i when i was
a founder i wasn't familiar with what
participating preferred meant or
super pro rada and we sometimes see
founders give up those terms without
totally understanding what they mean
and wow is this bad
um another example is board control you
can i've seen founders give up
control of their board such that they
could be fired and are fired
to raise a million dollars as a founder
like here's the trick
you're not going to be as good at this
as the person you're negotiating against
if they're an investor who invests in a
bunch of companies and you're a
first-time founder
so by using standard paperwork by using
a lawyer who actually has done a lot of
startup work
um you prevent yourself from getting
screwed and so this is one advantage of
trying to raise money from people that
have a track record of public companies
because you know they're optimizing for
you to build a really big company versus
some investors optimize for
your company is going to sell for 10 or
20 million dollars
and so they structure their entire
documents around that kind of outcome
this happens a lot internationally and
and
once again i don't think the investors
are being evil i think that they're
basically saying well i've never seen a
deal that's become a billion dollar
company
and so i've gotta optimize for these
base hits i gotta figure out if this
thing only sells for 20 million how does
my fund not die and i think that's like
so unfortunate because i think investors
oftentimes on a pitch oh we've got our
local experience so we have this we have
that but like
when you're a founder
it's way easier to get better terms from
someone who's passed than a billion
dollar company here's the last kind of
interesting way i've seen these terms
versus valuation
i give you a term sheet at a great
valuation
but the term is oh i'm going to only put
in 1 million
dollars and the term sheets for 3
million so you got to go out and find 2
more million somewhere else
where it's like oh this isn't this great
like i've got a term sheet and it's like
kinda i've got a deal like kinda you
have a deal but what is the investor
really doing when they give you an offer
like that what's really going on this
surprises a lot of people in yc but this
whole
hey this is great we love to invest when
you find a lead just come back when you
find a lead
if i translate that out of vc speak
actually means no
and founders are like what
means no
here's why
to the extent that you were in a
position where you did have a lead
investor it is very common that the lead
investor would want to put in the entire
amount of money to hit their ownership
target and so they would not
want you to give more
of the round to someone else
right not to mention if you had the lead
investor already lined up
there'd be a lot of other people that
would love to invest alongside the lead
investor and so when someone says
oh this is great come back to us when
you find a lead you know give us an
allocation in there what they're
actually getting is a free option
to invest in the future
if you find an investor that they are
impressed by
it costs them nothing to say that right
and
if you don't find a lead they just
manage to pass on your company while
being very nice to you to your face
yep right like it's like no we don't
want to invest but if you somehow find a
great lead investor and you come back to
us let's talk about it then
and
and the founder walks away from that
conversation like wow they're really
interested they want to invest we have
offers
when in fact they just did this ninja
move
where they said no
but that's not how you interpreted it
isn't that wild
it's almost as if they have to do this
because this is their job it's almost as
if they get to run this game every day
with multiple companies and all you're
trying to do is raise money and get back
to work
of course they're going to be better at
it of course they're going to have the
cool lines of course they're going to
tie you into knots it's like you apply
to a job
at facebook and they're like this is
great
come back to us
with your job offer from google and
apple
and
and we'll we'll can we'll go from there
so just let us know how it goes
right that's not a job offer consider
this a provisional job offer
assuming that you can get an offer from
google and apple
and like and and like even better like
sign something like like yeah like we'll
we'll sign something or we'll give you
something that looks official but and
again to be clear maybe maybe someone
will see this and be like oh but that's
you know what about this what about that
like sometimes there are cases of
investors that can't write big checks
and they want to invest alongside other
people this happens
sometimes that is possible so we're not
we're not suggesting this is all things
in all universes we're just saying a lot
of yc companies hear this line
and what it usually mean you know what
it means in our experience is no
let's talk about investor incentives
do you believe investors are
incentivized to tell companies to raise
more money or less money and why i think
it depends on the stage that the company
is at i think for tiny startups
investors aren't going to fund them
anyway and so saying
what they want to hear
like saying smart thing that captures
mind share so that when you do get
successful they'll want to come talk to
you not a bad idea and so i don't i
don't know what to perceive that i think
for companies that they actually want to
fund or perhaps they've already funded
i think it is reasonable as an investor
to want the company to get huge
investors are going for a huge outcome
so still with me right and so that often
looks like you should be growing faster
oh your revenue looks flat you should be
spending more on sales you should be
spending more on marketing and so coming
from a good place from their perspective
you might have a misalignment of
incentives sometimes where the investor
the worst thing you do for an investor
is like
be profitable but not grow fast enough
for them
versus if you're a founder that ain't so
bad
well i think what i've seen
is the investment community has changed
a lot and i think that
you know 10 years ago we were seeing a
lot more very small funds and a lot more
angels
investing in companies and
i would argue that they were
less professional
and i don't mean professional in a
in a good way i actually mean
professional in a bad way like
their interests were a lot more aligned
with the founder
i think that as
there have been more and more kind of
professional seed funds being built up
now those seed funds have obligations to
their lps to their investors
they have kind of internal
goals about how much of your company
they want to own to make sure their
business works and
as
the
seed funding world professionalizes it
opens up doors for there to be a
misalignment of incentives
i've seen a lot of situations where a
fund wants the founder wants the founder
to take more money not because they
think more moneys can help the company
but because they have an ownership
target because they want to own 10
percent
and so
i think that
nowadays that there's so much money out
there
investors have a lot more incentive to
convince founders they need more money
right money is what the investors are
selling when there's a lot of money out
there and a lot of investors out there
the easiest way to compete is like hey
i'll give you more money you need more
money let me try to make you afraid that
you don't have enough money so you'll
take my money and i think that's the
best founders understand that investors
have incentives on their own not bad or
good they're not evil or like angels
it's just more like we're investors too
michael yeah that's our agenda here
like i just think that like a smart
founder understands that people they're
negotiating with have their own goals
and incentives
and they take a second to think about
those incentives
when they're hearing the sales pitch
as opposed to just kind of believe
things blindly
you